contrary to popular belief the peanut is
not a nut
it's actually a vegetable belonging to
the legume family
which includes peas and beans these
tropical natives of south america
require about 120 days to mature
but fortunately the peanut plant can
withstand light spring and fall frosts
jumbo virginia is a productive variety
for home gardens
although the peanut plant is generally
considered a southern crop
northern gardeners can also grow them
successfully if they choose early
cultivars such as early spanish and
start plants indoors
planting peanuts peanuts need full sun
if you have heavy soil ensure good
drainage by working in enough organic
matter to make it loose and friable
peanut seeds come in their shells and
can be planted hulled or unheld
if you do shell them don't remove the
thin pinkish brown seed coverings or the
seed won't germinate
northern growers should start a peanut
plant indoors in a large peat pot a
month before the last frost
sow seeds one inch deep place in the
sunniest spot possible and water weekly
transplant peanut plant seedlings to the
garden when the soil warms to between 60
and 70 degrees
space transplants 10 inches apart being
careful not to damage or bury the crown
in the south plant outdoors around the
date of the last expected frost
space seeds 2 inches deep and 5 inches
apart in rows 2 to 3 feet apart
firm the soil and water well thin plants
to 10 inches apart
growing peanut plants when a peanut
plant is about a foot tall
hill the earth around the base of the
peanut plant
long pointed pegs also called peduncles
grow from faded flowers and then push
one to three inches down into the soil
beside the plant
a peanut will form on the end of each
peg lay down a light mulch
such as straw or grass clippings to
prevent the soil
surface from crusting so that the pegs
will have no difficulty penetrating the
soil
one inch of water a week is plenty a
peanut plant
being legumes peanuts supply their own
nitrogen
so avoid nitrogen-rich fertilizers which
encourage foliage rather than fruits
well-prepared soil will provide all the
nutrients the plants need
harvesting peanuts the crop is ready to
harvest when leaves turn yellow and the
peanuts inner shells have gold marked
veins which you can check periodically
by pulling out a few nuts from the soil
and shelling them
if you wait too long the pegs will
become brittle and the pods will break
off in the ground
making harvesting more difficult pull or
dig the plants and roots when the soil
is moist
shake off the excess soil and let plants
dry in an airy place until the leaves
become crumbly
then remove the pods unshelled peanuts
stored in airtight containers can keep
for up to a year